انا نتحول مشاهدينا مباشره لمتابعه هذه
الصور التي تاتينا من برازيليا في عقاب
تاديه الزعيم اليسار لويس سيلفا اليمين
الدستوريه رئيسا
للبرازيل اليوم الذي اذا كانت صور جاهزه
نعم نتابع هذه الصور اذا
الرئيس لويس
البرازيل
ويتم ذلك العاصمه
هيستابليست
من انصار سلفه بورسنارو بارتكاب اعمال عنف
اذا
يوقع الان
لسلفا
نتي
المره الثالثه
وال 2010
لولا ده سيلفا مشاهدينا كان نجح
في اخراج ملايين البرازيليين من الفقر
خلال ما سمي بتفره في اسعار السلع الاوليه
والتي دعمت الاقتصاد البرازيلي لكن
تدوررت
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه في بلاده
بانه افقر البلاد والعباد خلال هذه الفتره
وتعهد باعاده
انتعاش الاقتصاد في البلاد
يا كنترول دوريه زيرو داون ياهو هيافالي
دو برازوتي
كال اباده جماعيه
بسوء تعاملها مع جائع حتى كورونا
لانها اودت بحياه 680,000 برازيلي
ها بعد القاء القبض على رجل كان بحوزته
ابنه ناسفه وسكين في اثناء محاوله دخول
الساحه التي تقام فيها
تنصيب الرئيس المنتخب في برازيليا اذا
يقوم همم
الاوراق
ايضا في الاجراءات الامنيه كان تم القاء
القبض في ليله راس السنه على احد انصاررو
لانه صنع قنبله وتم اكتشافها في شاحنه
محمله بوقود الطائرات اذا اجواء الاحتفال
تستمر في برازيليا
وانتهت عمليه توقيع الاوراق والوثائق
الرسميه ويرتدي الرئيس
الذي كان من المفترض ان يتم تسليم ولكن
سافر الرئيس السابق ليتجنب هذه الخطوه بعد
ان خسر تاريخ
بعده كسيرانكو في دعدوزاسيناسيوس هي سبيشي
بوستيه موزي